donc aujourd'hui au programme on valoir
l'histoire de la croissance
démographique mondiale donc on va
construire un graphique qui va nous
présenter l'histoire de l'augmentation
de la population mondiale
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
marie
aride
bah y'a quelqu'un pour toi
[Musique]
je vais top dont bouquet merci c'est ce
que c'est que cette plante
oui c'est du gala baer le fait même des
dizaines de matches que ce soit d co une
semaine pour tout être l'oeuvre à
les éliminer elles sont pourris ou tu
vois toutes ces petites fleurs vont
donner naissance à des petits fruits
noirs qui contiennent des graines que
les oiseaux en est partout ce support
mais l'espace est à remarquer mais c'est
un peu en raison comme plante
[Musique]
et
c'est vraiment j'aime bien la vérité si
j' aime toutes les fleurs et chacun doit
pouvoir trouver sa place
cette flore là elle est égoïste elle
prend la place des autres et bouge pas
trop non non pas du tout si on fait pas
attention on valeur toute la diversité
des forêts réunionnaises et moi ça j'en
veux pas c'est trop triste
bon alors l'homme book et on joue pas ça
vu la tête qu'il a
[Musique]
en
au mas